no
improvviso inatteso accade nonostante i
nostri calcoli le nostre strategie
indipendentemente dalle nostre
aspettative
un volto uno sguardo un sorriso un
tratto del carattere uno stile di vita
un modo di essere
ci sorprendono ci colpiscono ci
catturano attraversano la nostra pelle e
ci raggiungono nella profondità della
nostra carne questo è possibile perché
la nostra pelle non è la superficie
delle applicazioni tecnologiche ma è il
bordeaux dove il corpo e lo spirito si
intrecciano la pelle ha infatti un lato
visibile che ci permette di entrare in
contatto con l'esterno con l'altro e un
risvolto interno un lato invisibile che
è strettamente collegato alla carne e fa
sì che noi siamo un tutt'uno e ci
disponiamo per così dire dalla pelle
alla carne dalla carne alla pelle è per
questo che noi siamo esposti dentro la
rete delle nostre connessioni quotidiane
nodo tra tantissimi nodi siamo esposti
al tocco inatteso dell'altro l'altro ci
tocca nella profondità la nostra carne
viene messa a nudo c decentriamo e
andiamo a ricercare colui che ci ha
toccato e non per cercare che cosa
l'altro mi può dare che rimane sempre in
un'ottica autocentrata egocentrica
ma per andare a scoprire chi è il volto
di quell'altro che nonostante la
relazione rimane sempre sulla soglia
della inaccessibilità il tocco di una
relazione autentica
può essere un'esperienza d'amore può
essere una relazione di amicizia può
essere un rapporto di solidarietà è e
rimane invisibile eppure ha una sua
visibilità e quella che io chiamo la
trasformazione condivisa della carne non
un cambiamento di superficie che rimane
lo schermo lo specchio del io ma un
cambiamento profondo in quella
profondità in cui siamo tutt'uno
emozioni sentimenti pensiero scelte
valori modi di vivere una trasformazione
della carne ma condivisa dove il con
l'insieme con l'altro non ha nulla
beh si esalta la differenza esalta
l'alterità la trasformazione condivisa
della carne e la traccia la nostra
traccia che incide il tempo del
cambiamento tecnologico proprio perché
trasforma lo spazio delle nostre
relazioni quotidiane
e questa la traccia la nostra traccia
unica originale relazionale che noi
consegniamo alla terra che noi
condividiamo e consegniamo alle
generazioni future
ma senza successo